all of these studies departments the
women's studies they literally hide
history if you request certain documents
they like ask you who you are they won't
give it to you yes yes because this is
what they say they say we're going to
rewrite like we're basically going to
read history from the like from the
point of view of the oppressed so what
is what does that switch it because now
you're they don't believe the writings
of the women at the time they don't
believe any of the historical evidence
it's like no we're going to put our spin
on history and now Make It Real History
yeah and the women's studies Department
they'll like hide Margaret singers like
racist rants all of her racist they
just hide